تطورات متسارعه بنسمعها وبنشوفها في واقع
التعرض اللاعب البرازيلي فينيسيوس لاهانات
عنصريه خلال مباراه ريال مدريد مع فالنسيا
بالدوري الاسباني واللي انتهت بطرد
فينيسيوس من المباراه الواقع هذه تحولت
لازمه عالميه دخلت فيها رئاسه البرازيل
واتحادات دول وانديه وشركات ولاعبين بداوا
في التضامن مع اللاعب اللي على فكره مو
اول مره بيتعرض للعنصريه والان اللي صار
في المباراه اتضحت صورته الى حد كبير
فخلال المباراه تعرض فينيسيوس لهتافات
عنصريه وتم وصفه بالقرد والجمهور صار يقلد
صوته حتى وتوجه وقتها فينيسيوس للجماهير
وشخص تحديدا كان بيوصفه بالقرد وقال له
هذا انت وبعدين اشتكى للحكم وقفت المباراه
عشر دقائق ودخل في نوبه بكاء وقال ما ابغى
اكمل لعب ونزل المدرب يهدي ويحضنه ورجعت
المباراه لكن في الوقت بدل الضائع اشتبك
مع اللاعبين فالنسيا والت الحكم بعد ما
رجع للفار وهو بيغادر ارض الملعب استمرت
الهتافات العنصريه الواقعه كلها جددت
الكلام على التصدي للعنصريه في الملاعب
وهذه المره يمكن بشكل اقوى من اي مره
ثانيا الجديد اليوم انه الاتحاد الاسباني
الغى البطاقه الحمراء ضد فينيسيوس خلال
المباراه وقالوا انه تقييم الحكم للي حصل
تم تحديده بعد اغفال الواقعه بالكامل وهذا
الشيء اثر على قراره في النهايه وقرر
الاتحاد كمان الاغلاق الجزئي لملعب نادي
بالامتيالي خمس مباريات قادمه وتغريم
النادي 45 الف يورو وهذه العقوبه هي
العقوبه الاقوى على الاطلاق في قضيه
عنصريه في كره القدم الاسبانيه اعترض
واستانف القرار وقال ان عقوبه غير عادله
وغير متناسبه وانه بيرفضها وشكى كمان من
انه ما اخذ فرصه يدافع عن نفسه قبل صدور
القرار وقال كمان احنا تعاونا مع الشرطه
من البدايه وقمنا كانت اللي حصل في الملعب
وساعدنا في تحديد هويه اشخاص من الهاتف
والهتافات العنصريه ومنعنا احدهم من دخول
ملاعبنا مدى الحياه يعني بيانهم كانهم
بيقولوا يعني نعمه ليش اكتر من كده يعني
قرار الاتحاد الاسباني كمان بخصوص الغاء
الطرد وايقاف اللعب عمل حاله من الجدل
والانقسام كمان ففي ناس اعتبرت ان هذا
القرار صح وما كان لازم ينطرد فينيسيوس
لانه الحكم ما طرد لاعب باللي هو اعتدى هو
كمان على بني وناس ثانيه شافته خطوه في
طريق مواجهه العنصريه وعقوبه كويسه ضد
النادي وفي ناس عارضت القرار وقالت كيف
تتلغي بطاقه حمراء وكان ملفت انه في ناس
اصلا داعمه الفينيسيوس ومتضامنه مع ضد
العنصريه لكنها معارضه قرار الغاء طرده
مثل شعبي مدرب برشلونه مثلا اللي قال انا
اتضامنت معاه وادمنت العنصريه لكن ما يجوز
خلط الامور وكان في اعتداء واضح ومعرف لاي
درجه الغاء الطرد عادل وفي قسم من الناس
اعتبر انه كل القرار مو مهم بقدر ما هو
المهم اتخاذ خطوات عمليه ضد العنصريه بحد
ذاتها هو العنصريين يعني ازمه جالسه
بتتوسع وبتكبر وحملات التضامن مع فيني
كمان جزء بتتوسع فمن بعد ما دعمته شركه
بومه امس اللي هي على فكره راعي فريق
بلنسيا نشرت شركه نايكي كمان تغريده فيها
صوره لفينيسيوس وعنواناتها بنحن معك اما
شعبيا ففي البرازيل كان جمع حوالي مئه
متظاهر خارج القنصليه في سان باولو طالبوا
بايقاف العنصريه في اسبانيا
والبرازيل وحملوا لافتات عليها عبارات دعم
ليفينيسيوس ومحاربه للعنصريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]